car mercredi sortie du dernier film de
cédric klapisch paris rien à voir avec
le berger espagnole et les poupées
russes
le réalisateur nous propose une galerie
de portraits incarné par un casting
impressionnant
on y retrouve son acteur fétiche romain
duris aux côtés de juliette binoche et
fabrice luchini qui est avec nous ce
soir
laetitia fernandez et guinevere nous
dévoile les intrigues du film dans le
paris de cédric klapisch les êtres se
croiser parfois se lit il y à la
boulangère légèrement raciste le propre
histoire qui s'amourache d'une jeune et
jolie étudiante l'assistante sociale
célibataire et désemparé et son frère
gravement malade qui doit réapprendre à
vivre et à regarder les autres
je crois qu'avec aussi ça
peut-être parce que les jolies là bas
c'est pas parce qu'on fait de la comédie
ou qu'on fait rire qu'on n'a pas le
droit de pleurer ou d'aller vers des
émotions qui sont plus profondes et là
ça parle de la mort parce que je me suis
rendu compte que quand on veut parler de
la vie finalement la vie elle prend tout
son sens quand on compte y est la
proximité de la mort et quand on risque
quand quand on sait qu'on risque de
mourir quand j'avais oublié que cela
pouvait tout aussi bien celles en tant
que la haute antiquité savoir agathois
le gris - sur cette table bah je crois
que la date de la dernière fois est un
des quelques dents au moyen-âge je fasse
ma [ __ ] au carbone 14 pour en être sûr
romain duris chrome pour la sixième fois
avec le réalisateur un rôle inhabituel
pour l'acteur fétiche de sénèque l'api
sur tout ce qu'on voulait et c'est vrai
que c'est que ce personnage là il gagne
quelque chose quoi l'idée de la mort qui
se rapprochent qu'il apprenne quelque
chose qui gagnent de cet état un peu
contemplatif est en standby quoi j'ai un
truc au coeur à s'allonger mais plus
pour très longtemps
il faut que tu n'as pas parler avant que
je l'attendais tuera tous non mais
justement je suis pas tout le monde se
débat comme elle peut jusqu'au moment où
finalement elle va elle va trouver
grâce à son frère un peu à peu d'amour
dans sa ville je lui comme aux adultes
rendu plus émouvant ce film nous
rappelle une chose la vie courte
ne perdons pas un instant nous pensons
intéresse pas